sie wollen auf und davon
birgitt und jürgen haben kinder
großgezogen jetzt ziehen sie los auf die
philippinen
die familie fischer aus dem aargau
wünscht sich mehr lebensqualität
sie bricht auf in die weite kanadas von
appenzell ans mittelmeer
monika und bert daniela folgen ihren
traum sie bauen ein kleines hotel in der
türkei
[Musik]
in türkischen wirtschaft der polin
monika und wärtern einen olivenbaum
abholen
denn ein olivenbaum so heißt es bringe
glück ist etwas nicht doch alles okay
aber wir brauchen einen traktor und die
häufig sagt dass er wohl ewig die ganze
branche angekommen wir versuchen einen
traktor zu organisieren der gärtner hat
die größe des olivenbaums unterschätzt
der olivenbaum wiegt schwer und lässt
sich deshalb nicht einfach einpacken und
weg kann nur ein richtiger traktor kann
so viel glück transportieren
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
kehrten monika und wärtern von ihrer
einkaufstour zurück ihre heimkehr
feierten sind gebührend im fertigen
hotel rohbau konnten sie endlich mit dem
innenausbau beginnen in kanada schnitzen
annett und die kinder kürbisse für
halloween die fischers fanden endlich
ihr traumhaus nach zwei monaten auf dem
campingplatz zog die familie auf ihren
eigenen grund und boden in jungle beach
resort auf palawan kann der bau der
bungalows gut voran
doch noch immer platten berge 10
schmerzen an beinen und füßen
monika und bergbahnen fahren vorerst
ohne olivenbaum zum hotel zurück
ein traktor war nicht aufzutreiben der
olivenbaum und glücksbringer muss
nachgeliefert werden
bei ihrem hotel ist alles ruhig zu ruhig
kein baulärm stört die idylle für die
schafe macht das gut sein für die
künftigen hoteliers jedoch ist eine
kleine katastrophe ihr hotel ist
eigentlich fast fertig es fehlt nur noch
das terrassendach seit zwei wochen
warten monika und berta auf den
zimmermann in einem monat schon beginnt
die sommersaison
doch kurz vor dem endspurt steht alles
still unzählige male hat wert an den
zimmermann bereits angerufen
immer wieder wurde er vertröstet soll
ich jetzt den kram für morgen
organisieren
erst am abend ja was soll ich dazu sagen
was soll ich dazu sagen okay ich rufe
dich um 5 uhr an die städte anspannung
macht auch monika wieder zur raucherin
solange die terrasse nicht fertig gebaut
ist so lange können die beiden wegen des
drecks die gästezimmer nicht einrichten
kommt hinzu wörtern und monika müssen
selber bald ins hotel einziehen
mal wenn du morgen nicht kommt dann hole
ich das holz ab das problem ist in zwei
tagen muss das haus fertig sein weil wir
dann einziehen müssen wir müssen aus der
mietwohnung raus verstehst was ich meine
die fast zwei wochen breitmacht
ok ich erwarte eine antwort
ich erwarte deine antwort
[Musik]
die erste nacht auf ihrem land
verbrachte die familie fischer noch im
camp
muss ich die virtuelle tage heute
erobern sie ihr haus sie ziehen ein
camper lebten sie auf 32 quadratmetern
ihr traumhaus bietet zehnmal so viel
platz annett ist noch ein wenig
erschlagen von der größe der küche
[Musik]
einen container mit 170 schachteln haben
die fischers nach kanada verfrachtet
[Musik]
ihr ganzes hab und gut aus dem
aargauischen staufen bekommt nun ein
neues plätzchen und mit jeder schachtel
die ausgepackt wird zieht ein stück
heimat ein
[Musik]
floss in das feld ist positiv
er stehe immer noch so viele politiker
so viele neues worden fotos zu machen
und da hatte ich jetzt nicht nur energie
sondern zum bmw das haus renovieren
[Musik]
gold bleibt nicht viel zeit er muss auf
montage vor der hand ist er zufrieden
wenn die zimmer mit dem nötigsten
eingerichtet sind
[Musik]
extremsport dänische
die wagen sind als kritisch da braucht
man im labor juni
da habe ich damit
ich möchte den klub
[Musik]
doch ruhe die mayersche
es gehört eigentlich nicht zu jörg sens
lieblingsbeschäftigung mit der hündin
gina zu spielen
doch er hat keine wahl mehr geht die
sich sonst stunden lang um die tiere
kümmert ist weg sie ist in die schweiz
geflogen um sich einem gesundheitscheck
zu unterziehen
[Musik]
ich meine was mache ich eigentlich
müsstet ihr zieht und der gage
philippinen sammeln und den und deshalb
nein das ballkleid das ist ja nicht
unbedingt venture ist eine umgestaltung
seit wochen leidet seine frau unter
schmerzen an beinen und füßen
[Musik]
in ihrer heimat in zürich will mehr
dezent unendlich erfahren was mit ihren
beinen und füßen los ist das gehen fällt
ihr schwer
und sie hat sichtlich abgenommen
vor vier wochen
es ist einfach weg für die dabei und
eine schleppe steht und jetzt die macht
zusichern die wurzeln des filial es
vorerst steht die ärztliche untersuchung
an
nach wochenlangen leiden will birgit
klarheit haben
[Musik]
in al assad der neigt sich der tag
langsam dem ende zu touristen genießen
die laue frühlingsluft die marktbesucher
gehen nach hause
und auch die bauarbeiter haben
feierabend
nur die künftigen hoteliers können sich
keine ruhe
sie streichen ihre gartenbau noch immer
warten sie auf die lieferung des
terrassen balkens merthan ist sauer
verhalten reagieren wir jedoch noch nie
gehabt
die beiden arbeiten bis tief in die
nacht hinein
es bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit bis die
ersten gäste kommen
[Musik]
in den frühen morgenstunden sind die
beiden auswanderer bereits wieder am
malen
trotz wenig schlaf ist wörtern frohen
mutes wir es gestern zu mir versprochen
hat am mittag sollte er da sein
kaum hat bert an den anruf beendet steht
der kran auch schon vor dem hotel
der kranführer rief den tonnenschweren
balken über die gartenmauer
mit dem balken kehrt auch das glück ein
fünf männer braucht es um den olivenbaum
in den garten zu wuchten
geht es da nicht was wir je nach leuten
ist es wirklich gut geworden
jetzt bin ich ein bisschen
wieder motiviert bin ich wieder im
element jährlich sagen bin nicht
vertrauen
wir machen lernen das ist auch gut
dann hört man das erarbeiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so gerät die familie fischer erkundet
ihr grundstück zwei hektaren land
gehören ihnen ganz alleine zwei hektaren
land die genutzt werden wollen und
logische riesengroße sehen die
wirtschaft und was heißt ohne ein wenig
an machen stellen
ich weiß nicht
[Musik]
us ganztag
es ist schon schön wenn der tank tun
haben und die ihre ruhe einfach nicht
deutlich genug machen
[Musik]
bittere zutat in der tollen mischung
kommt muss noch gleichentags abreisen
er geht für eine woche auf montage
[Musik]
mit seinem schweizer chef bert schwaller
und zwei arbeitskollegen fährt kurz 400
kilometer in den süden
ein schwapp lake werden vier männer ein
blockhaus aufrichten dann aber das
blockhaus und der neuland für mich die
klinischen bis 9
geordnet hat
wieso
[Musik]
birgit ist auf dem weg zum orthopädie
stn
noch immer hat sie einen unsicheren gang
doch sie ist erleichtert
nach einer gründlichen untersuchung im
spittaler der leiden einen namen
birgit hat einen fall fuß bei einem fall
fuß ist ein erbe schädigt welche für das
heben des fußes zuständig ist
es kommt zu lähmungserscheinungen
ein normaler gang ist nicht mehr möglich
ja spielerinnen haben sich vorsitzende
unbedingt abklären soll energie beide
unterschenkel eben einfach die bewegung
also jetzt schon wieder nehmen machen
und dann bin ich immer meine eigene für
seine kate und ja die 20 musiker aus
china mitgebracht winkel statt und über
die vier sind okay dass ich hier zeigen
warum bin ich jetzt auch frau die passt
auch gerade prozent das einfachste wäre
die einfache plastikschiene so sieht das
aus relativ einfach
tja und gar nicht so stabil
die schiene soll birgit beim gehen
helfen und sie vor stürzen bewahren
sie muss getragen werden bis sich der
nerv wieder regeneriert hat wie lange
das dauern wird ist ungewiss
[Musik]
zur stütze des rechten fußes genügt eine
bandage an diesem fuß hat sich der
beschädigten erft bereits wieder ein
wenig erholt ganze komplex oder und das
ist also möglich
ich habe da schon wieder heben oder
prognose
[Musik]
diagnose die prognosen hat sehr stark
nicht reduziert das machten sie die fünf
monaten wieder 46
das akzeptiert dass man dann
unterversorgt ich mit vista mineralien
vitamine anorexie liter sei aber ich
finde mich nicht an wie sie das gemacht
haben ja noch sichtlich ja ich habe mich
ins spital gelegt und gesagt macht mir
einen magenbypass okay man sieht auch
nicht so voll ich bin voll gesund wie
weit sich birgit nerven wieder
regenerieren wird sich weisen sicher ist
birgit hat als sie sich den magen bypass
legen ließ mögliche nebenwirkungen
unterschätzt nach einer solchen
operation ist eine ausgewogene ernährung
besonders wichtig bei birgit traten
fatale mangelerscheinungen auf ihre
hoffnung sind nun vitaminpräparate nur
wenn diese helfen kann sie die schiene
wieder abnehmen
es ist lärmig auf dem bau was für
wörtern wie musik in den ohren klingt
ist für den schafhirten und seine tiere
nur krach sie ziehen ab jetzt wo das
terrassendach steht können monika und
wörtern endlich die zimmer einrichten
monika bringt die ausgewählte bettwäsche
ins hotel sowie erst der
einrichtungsgegenstände wie lampen und
wohnaccessoires dinge die ihr hotel
einzigartig machen sollen
kaum hat monika mit dem einrichten der
zimmer begonnen zieht weiteres unheil
auf forbert ins auge
ein wasserrohr ist geborsten direkt vor
der hoteltüre
oh mein gott schon glaubt doch macht
daraufhin den rohrleitungen
[Applaus]
weder muss monika warten und diese
warterei erträgt sie kaum mehr sind die
für sie machen sehr komische sachen
jetzt freue ich mich einfach nicht
[Musik]
doch wann immer einen der beiden
auswanderer die kraft zu verlassen droht
übernimmt automatisch der andere das
zepter werthan bleibt gelassen und im
handumdrehen ist der schaden behoben
bleibt noch ihr olivenbaum
dieser soll nun in ihrem garten heimisch
werden und tiefe wurzeln schlagen
neben immer gleich mit dem männer aber
will es um schwere sachen wasser gehen
in jungle beach resort auf den
philippinen wird ebenfalls im garten
gearbeitet
ein großer teil des geländes wurde neu
gepflanzt
die jungen pflanzen benötigen täglich
viel wasser
[Musik]
der kaffee ist vielleicht zu stark
scheint zufrieden noch ist birgit zwar
in der schweiz
doch es geht ihr täglich besser so kann
sich jörg getrost um das weitere italien
des resorts kümmern wenn die sands einst
gäste haben dann werden sie noch mehr
wasser brauchen
und genau das könnte zu schwierigkeiten
führen
pass auf mit dem messer heute wie sich
jörg diesem problem annehmen mit der
angestellten der serie möchte er zur
quelle vorstoßen
zur blue lagoon die bruder gut versorgt
in paraguay auf deutsch die gemeinde mit
wasser da die gemeindemitglieder sich
nicht gerne von fremden das wasser
abgraben lassen hat der bezirkschef den
sens einen handel vorgeschlagen diese
marode schlauch führt das wasser von der
quelle zu den häusern die luft sauber
450 meter neue schloss holte damit den
bauern bei und mir wieder altenburg
wasserdruck an dem morgen um was er sich
eigentlich an wird der weg für die
aktiva in den dschungel zu einer kleinen
siedlung
das ist die großmutter von einem
angestellten ernannte
[Musik]
das ist ein café baum
sie werden die davon bringen
dass sie jetzt etwa die lagune die jury
bru lagoon also grünen braunlage kleine
zuhörer aus dem tempo das ganze wasser
braust für eine ganze baureihe
das ist das quellwasser also das problem
rost und trinken auf die fahrbahn
ob die sens neue schläuche finanzieren
werden das will jörg zuerst mit birgit
besprechen
[Musik]
400 kilometer von seiner familie
entfernt baut kurt fischer am schuh
blake sein erstes blockhaus in nur zehn
tagen richtet kurt mit seinen kollegen
das riesige blockhaus auf
[Musik]
640 quadratmeter wohnfläche soll es 1
bieten
[Musik]
und während kurt mit muskelkraft und dem
20 kilogramm schweren sogenannten panda
einen massiven schwalbenschwanz posten
in die richtige position schlägt müht
sich annett mit einem einfachen aber
sperrigen regal aus sperrholz ab
weißt du kann
jetzt konnte ich dann hier staunt
[Musik]
und dann wieder fehler
aber das dauert und kontinuität
mit dem taxi unterwegs zum flughafen von
manila
endlich kann jörg seine perlet abholen
jörg ist glücklich dass es seiner frau
besser geht
so schwer sie glaubt dass der hof
gesehen
es liegen
wenn sie den darum ist die ausstehenden
klagen hin können
davor liegen wie es neue schlappen auto
und bin
wo sie nicht starten kann
[Musik]
die bühne
gießen
viele unterbieten
[Musik]
mit der fuß schiene ist birgit gang
wieder sicher und geschmeidig
[Musik]
in kanada am schuh blake hat es zu
schneien begonnen schon ein paar wenige
schneeflocken sind ein problem
frieren sie ein werden sie zu
gefährlichem mit einem heißluft rechner
soll dies verhindert werden doch
rutschig bleiben die balken allemal
mai kommt nicht
schule muss aufpassen dass sich aber
dummerweise kontinenten reinigt man sich
zieht wird auch weniger gefährlich
gerade mal vier arbeiter bauen das
blockhaus auf die arbeitstage sind lang
manchmal schuftet kurz 15 stunden
doch immerhin kann kurt nun als
angestellter zum ersten mal über zeit
kompensieren
[Musik]
in einem haus gleich neben der baustelle
gelegen sind die arbeiter untergebracht
die kumpels kochen und essen zusammen
der einst selbstständige zimmermann
kurth ist nun teil eines teams dank ios
sich ihren traktor aneinander sodass das
filmische viel härter schaffte eine
längere stunden und so und ja das ist
mir aus kann der sicheren stelle hier
aber ist und sich gut dass ich etwas tue
im team
[Musik]
lexus noch strom
nein was kein strom wir schlafen doch
hier dann machen wir unsere mündlich mit
kerzenlicht kein strom kein wasser wie
romantisch mittlerweile beunruhigen
monika weder der mangel an wasser noch
der fehlende strom
denn der bau des hotels neigt sich dem
ende zu
die stimmung ist gelöst der ersten nacht
in ihrem neuen zuhause steht nichts mehr
im weg monika bereitet der zähler vor
als schwierig zu pflegen
das erste mobile tripolis
anfänglich wurde monika als frau auf dem
bau oft belächelt mittlerweile hat sie
sich respekt verschafft und die arbeiter
akzeptieren sie rosa wann gehst du ich
warte auf wörter man konnte in einer
halben stunde den olivenbaum muss man
noch wasser geben einmal pro tag haben
sie gesagt ich habe immer morgen zwei
eimer wasser gegeben
danke du bist unser bester mitarbeiter
gleich zu machen
[Musik]
nach acht monaten bauzeit steht das
hotel in wenigen wochen übernachten hier
die ersten gäste
[Musik]
kaum wieder in ihrer neuen heimat auf
palawan angekommen sagt birgit etwas auf
das sie lange verzichten musste sie geht
schnorcheln
[Musik]
jörg verfolgt das ganze vom ufer aus
während in china die gelegenheit zum
spielen nutzen will
[Musik]
dieser moment muss festgehalten werden
hätte ich über wie gewollt
yeah
zwei minuten davor
[Musik]
dem vierjährigen töchterchen kann die
mutter noch etwas vormachen sich selber
nicht
annette sich versichern dass ihr sohn
pauli gut nach hause kommt heute fährt
er zum ersten mal alleine mit dem
schulbus mit kristin fährt eine deshalb
zur schule umzuschauen dass paule in den
richtigen bus einsteigt dennoch spricht
der kleine junge kaum englisch heißt die
fahrerin ist sie nicht hier sind sie die
busfahrerin das ist paul
er muss beim englisch place aussteigen
okay kein problem
er weiß wohl nicht hohe aussteigen muss
können sie sagen hallo du passt auf ihn
auf großartig
[Applaus]
und wenn wir gern mit deutschen kliniken
muss ich sagen sie dafür genau die waage
dank
[Musik]
um sicherzugehen dass of police weg zum
richtigen kanadier nichts schief läuft
fährt mit dem auto hinter dem bus her
mit dem tisch
ja
5 die stiege mit führungsstärke
juli stiegen die löhne stecken
ich versuchte ihn zurückzuhalten na ja
er hat falsch im kopf noch einmal gut
gegangen doch was wenn die mutter nicht
mehr dabei ist in der nächsten und
letzten folge von auf und davon kommt
beule in der schule nicht an guten
morgen haben sie paul gesehen
sie haben sie paul gesehen ich weiß
nicht obwohl das hotel in aller taten
noch nicht eröffnet ist wurden schon
erste gäste ein zimmer mieten
währenddessen ist auf palawan das resort
bereits ausgebucht die sonst ziehen um
und überlassen ihren eigenen bungalow
den gästen beim packen entdeckt birge
dem schrank spuren von mäusen
die villa ist
es ist toll
[Musik]
vivendi hat diese taschen falsch